*Cris de joie*
Yes !
Le million d'euros !
Le succès, ça, on l'avait pas anticipé à ce point en tout cas.
*Sirène mégaphone*
Et ça renvoie une image qui est super pour le gaming
et pour tout ce qu'on fait dans le streaming.
Quand il faut se réunir pour le bien,
on sait le faire.
Sans le public, on est rien.
Cet événement, il existe que grâce au public.
Et c'est juste fou que les gens soient réunis autour d'une cause qui est positive.
7000 balles avant le million !
Waouh !
Si Pasteur voyait ça aujourd'hui, il en serait, je pense,
extrêmement émuet reconnaissant !
Pasteur !
On va faire trembler l'univers.
On va se faire entendre, croyez-moi.
Venez, suivez-moi !
Allez, on y va.
Tiens Dach, viens !
*Sirène mégaphone*
Le silence s’il vous plaît.
Bon déjà, merci à tous d’être là.
Vraiment, c’est cool.
On va commencer sur une note positive.
Plaisir de vous accueillir.
Je sais qu’il y a des problèmes de Net, etc.
On fait au mieux, merci pour votre patience,
on va essayer de régler ça dans les temps.
En tout cas, merci de répondre présent
comme chaque année.
Bienvenue aux nouveaux, on est contents de vous avoir.
Les nouveaux !
Bienvenue aux nouveaux, on est content de vous avoir.
*Applaudissements*
Normalement, je pense que vous connaissez le principe,
il y a pas de grosses guidelines,
on vous fait globalement confiance pour gérer votre planning.
Essayez quand même, dans la mesure du possible,
de respecter la seule consigne qui était :
“On dépasse pas 25 heures de live d’affilée en non-stop.”
Si vous avez les moyens, le but, c’est pas de faire les putes à cliques
mais encouragez vraiment les gens à faire des dons, même de 1 euro.
Je préfère que vous soyez 10 000, 20 000
à donner 1 euroque 10 000, 20 000,
à rien faire parce que vous pouvez pas donner grand-chose.
N’hésitez pas à raid les autres pour aller voir leur donation goal
et donner envie à vos viewers de donner chez les autres.
Kameto ! Kameto !
Notamment chez Kameto  qui veut rentrer en vélo à Marseille.
À 18h, vous venez tous derrière moi sur la chaise comme d’habitude,
pour ceux qui connaissent.
Moi, je vais dire : “Salut, c’est énorme, on lance Z Event.”
Et en gros, je dis :
“Allez, vous pouvez y aller.”
Et là, tout le monde va sur son ordi.
Et là, vous pouvez allumer vos lives à ce moment-là avec la cam.
Le Z Event, c’est un évènement qui dure un week-end,
où on se retrouve à plein de streamers.
Là, en l'occurrence, 56.
Chacun lance sa chaîne en direct.
On joue à des jeux vidéo, on fait des quiz,
on chante, on fait de la musique,
on fait pleinde bêtises.
Et le but, c’est de lever des fonds pour une association.
Cette année, c’est l'Institut Pasteur.
L’année dernière, c’était Médecins Sans Frontières
avec plus d’1 million d’euros récoltés.
*Sifflements*
J’adore accueillir les gens
et j’espère que tout le monde va bien s’y sentir
et mon gros objectif,
c’est que tout le monde reparte avec des étoiles dans les yeux.
Oubliez pas que Zerator est toléré dans cet event.
On est encore plus que l'an dernier,
on est énormément nombreux,
toujours pour soutenir la bonne cause, bien sûr.
Donc plus on est, plus on va rire, déjà.
Et surtout, plus on va ramasser, j'espère, de donations
et exploser le record de 1 millionde l'an dernier.
Il y a des gens qui font du rec, il y a des gens qui vont beaucoup discuter,
il y a des gens qui vont faire de la musique.
MV, par exemple fait du jeu vidéo mais
l'an dernier, son titre incontournable"J'adore Le Zboub" avait affolé la toile.
J'ai toujours aimé
Donc, chacun y va un petit peu de son petit truc
mais il y a pas que du jeu vidéo, en effet.
C'est du partage avant tout.
On est souvent très seuls dans le milieu du streaming
parce qu’on est tous devant nos pc, etc.
et là, on se retrouve tous ensemble comme une grosse colonie de vacances.
On a tous prévu des goals.
Moi, je sais que je vais jouer à un jeu qui s’appelle Euro Trucks,
qui est un jeu de simulation de camions.
Alors, ça peut paraîtreultra relou comme ça
mais en fait, moi, j’aime bienécraser les voitures,
conduire très mal donc c’est très drôle, j’ai ramené le volant, etc.
On va beaucoup traîner sur les lives des autres.
On prévoit beaucoup de choses en général mais le week-end passe
très, très vite.
Du coup, ça va être vraimentde l’improvisation aussi.
Un des trucs qui est vachement important, je trouve,
en tout cas dans le stream, c’est l’improvisation.
C’est le fait de pas trop prévoir ce qu’on fait et surtout interagir
avec tous les gens qui sont ici.
Ça serait...
Ça serait un peu dommage d’être ici et de faire comme s'il y avait personne d’autre.
Allez, venez.
On n'est pas très grands...
Faites-moi une pyramide de gens, là.
3,
2,
1...
*Cris de joie*
Bonsoir !
Bienvenue à Z Event.
Ça va derrière ?
Ah, ça fait plus de bruit que prévu !
Ok !
Bon, vous voyez, on est très nombreux,
ça devient de plus en plus difficile chaque année de faire rentrer
tout le monde dans cette caméramais on a essayé de faire
le maximum qu'on pouvait.
Tout le monde est là,
tout le monde est prêt sur ses lives.
Donc, je déclare Z Event 2019 ouvert !
Et vous pouvez...
*Applaudissements*
Vous pouvez aller live !
À vos lives,
prêts,
streamez !
Tout le monde va se déplacer et aller directement sur son live.
100 balles Bob le pingouin.
100 balles, on en est déjà à 5500 balles.
T’as fait un effort sur la qualité de la caméra, j’ai l’impression...
C’est faux ! C’est pixellisé.
Les dons arrivent ici.
On voit toutes les personnes qui font les dons actuellement.
Cet écran est très important, je vais passer beaucoup de temps à le regarder.
Mais le début, c’est pang !
Ça part très, très fort en général.
Après, au milieu, demain par exemple, ça va ralentir
et vers la fin, ça va être insane, ça va réaccélérer à fond.
250 balles !
Merci beaucoup pour les 250 balles.
Je trouve que ça ressemble à la bourse de New York,
c’est à ça que ça me fait penser.
C’est mon moment préféré.
Le début et la fin, c’est là où il y a le plus d’activité
et où l’ambiance est partout autour de nous et il y a le brouhaha permanent,
je suis hyper fan de ça.
Nous avons atteint 100 000 euros mesdames et messieurs.
*Applaudissements*
L'idée de Z Event, enfin,l'historique remonte à 2016,
où en fait, Adrien et plusieurs autres streamers du marché français,
faisaient partie d’un collectif qui s’appelle Avengers.
Le principe d’Avengers, c’est que le collectif réagit en situation de crise et d’urgence
pour soutenir des causes qui sont pas très médiatisées
et donc, c’est Adrien qui avait eu cette idée, qui m’a dit :
"Ah ça serait cool qu’on invite quelques potes et qu’on se fasse un truc à la maison,
tout simple où voilà, on se fait du stream en groupe,
une petite LAN à notre manière et on joue tous ensemble pour récolter des fonds.
Le tout premier Avengers, on était peut-être 12, 13
chez Zerator, donc à l’ancienne,vraiment en mode la petite LAN entre potes
sauf que c’est pour du caritatif.
On est avec plein de gens, ici, chez moi,
dans la petite maison.
Regardez, je vous montre très rapidement ce qu’il se passe ici.
Il y a le projet Avengers qui a été déclenché
à cause d’une grande sécheresse, incroyable, qui se passe en Éthiopie.
C’est Lege derrière.
Et on a levé 172 000 euros je crois,
ce qui, à l’époque, pour nous, était impensable,
surtout en 3 jours.
Et en fait, c’est comme ça qu’on a eu l’idée de Z Event 2017
et on a monté le premier événement comme ça,
pareil, dans le garage, fait à la main.
Ça faisait hyper underground, roots et voilà,
c’était juste les potes qui se réunissent à nouveau.
Je déclare la cérémonie de Z Event et son événement ouverts.
Messieurs, allez sur vos lives.
C'est parti !
C'est né comme ça mais ça vient juste d’un désir personnel de Zerator
et moi-même de soutenir une cause parce qu’on trouve que c’est important de le faire.
Woah, attention, attention, oh !
On a failli mourir.
C’est un tournoi Beat Saber donc ça permet un petit peu
de faire connaissance avec des streamers qu’on connaissait pas
ou juste passer un bon moment sur le stream.
Ça vient un petit peu unifier
toute cette communauté en rapprochant tous les streamers
donc c’est cool.
Lutti, il y a 12 000 personnes.
Ok !
Aucun stress.
C’est plus que la finale de l’Overwatch League.
*Rires*
Non !
C’est vachement dur putain.
500 000 euros mesdames et messieurs !!
*Applaudissements*
Bravo à tous !
C’est génial mais ça ne m’étonne pas
parce que je sais que justement toutes ces communautés sont extrêmement investies,
c’est-à-dire qu’à l’heure actuelle, t'as énormément de gens qui regardent Twitch,
qui regardent YouTube, qui sont sur les réseaux sociaux.
Moi, j’ai débuté en 2011, 2012.
Et quand je fais le comparatif, ça a rien à voir.
On avait des vidéos en qualité dégueu, en 480p.
On streamait sur des plateformes comme Dailymotion.
Vu l’évolution spectaculairelà en 5 à 7 ans,
je me dis que dans 10 ou 20 ans,
ça peut être hyper impressionnant avec des prods encore plus folles,
avec un public encore plus vaste
et surtout, avec une diversité encore plus large de jeux,
de types de formats, de profils qui travaillent dans cette industrie.
Course de chaises ?
Ouais, vas-y, je suis chaud.
Domingo ?
Ouais ?
Tu veux faire une course de chaises ?
Je suis chaud pour une course de chaises !
C’est qui ton binôme?
J’ai pas de binôme, j’ai pas d’amis.
On le fait où ?
On le fait là ?
Enchanté.
T’inquiète hein, j’ai le permis.
*Rires*
Il faut que les deux joueurs touchent le câble, ok?
Au niveau de leurs pieds.
La première, la première.
Et la fin...
5,
Tu bombardes, Lock.
4,
Tu bombardes.
3,
2,
1,
Yes !
Stop !
Lock, t'as pas encore touché les pieds !
Ça repart !
Vas-y, vas-y !
Oui !
Vas-y !
Victoire !
Ouais !
BOOM !
J’étais en situation de soulevage.
Je suis quand même fier.
Bien joué.
Eh bien j’ai plus de chaise du coup.
L’avantage, c’est qu’on est très créatifs chez les Français et on se tire tous vers le haut
en voyant que "oh y a un tel qui a fait ça, c’est trop bien".
Gotaga qui a fait un Gotaga Show, un show monstrueux sur Fortnite,
qui fait 250 000 viewers...
tous les créateurs de contenus regardent et se disent : ah ouais !
Même si je joue pas à Fortnite ou autre, c'est quand même génial ce qu'il a fait
et ça donne des idées, ça donne des envies.
Zerator qui organise ses Z Events, les ZLAN, les Trackmania Cup, donc voilà,
ça donne envie de faire des choses.
En fait, on a le rush du million qui arrive.
On a dit qu’on le ferait avant midi.
Il doit rester 8000 balles à faire.
Du coup, là, on va booster les dons, booster, booster !
On peut le faire !
Il reste 7000 balles.
Allez merci pour les 10 euros.
Dans 6 minutes !
Merci pour les 20 euros.
6 minutes avant…
7000 balles avant le million !
Plus que 7000 balles.
Allez, plus que 5000 euros,
5000 euros et on va arriver au million.
C’est maintenant, tous les petits dons,
les 1, les 5, les 10, les 20, c’est maintenant !
Tout le monde !
Faites des dons !
Allez, allez, allez !
Allez !
500 euros !
Road to 80 000 !
On est en train de faire la plus belle...
Vous vous rendez pas compte,
c’est historique là !
Allez, allez !
Le million !!!
*Sirène mégaphone*
1 million d’euros mesdames et messieurs !
*Applaudissements*
Et voilà !
Incroyable, merci à toutes et à tous !
Merci à ceux du matin qui ont fait le grand rush.
Incroyable d’atteindre cette somme aussi vite.
Il reste encore un peu de temps.
Est-ce qu’on peut arriver à 2 millions?
J’étais dans ma chambre
qui est à 10 minutes à pied.
Je suis venu en 3 minutes, je crois.
On m’a dit : “Il y a bientôt le million, dépêche-toi.”
J’ai couru.
J’en peux plus, je suis mort.
La somme levée est incroyable.
On a tellement d’avance par rapport à l’an dernier.
Va falloir faire mieux !
Merci pour votre grain de sable.
Merci beaucoup !
Merci.
Merci pour tes 12 euros.
L’année dernière à la même période, on était à genre 400 000 euros
donc ça a rien à voir.
Il est arrivé en courant, il transpire de ouf.
Ok, repose-toi, sois en forme pour ce soir.
Ouais.
Il va falloir aller donner sur le stream de Kameto.
D'accord ?
Ah ça y est, ça y est, t’as la cagnotte de Kameto.
Ok nickel, nickel.
Ce que font les streamers, notamment Squeezie et Zerator là-bas,
ils font ce qu’on appelle des raids.
Donc, en gros, ils encouragent leurs spectateurs à eux
à aller sur les directs des autres animateurs
pour qu’ils arrivent à atteindre leurs objectifs qu’ils se sont fixés financièrement
et en général, moyennant l’objectif atteint, ils ont un gage.
Donc, par exemple, Kamel rentre à Marseille en vélo.
Il y a 1000 euros par minute sur ton live.
Allez, allez.
Oh, la sauce !
Kamel, il va rentrer en vélo !
Ça monte trop vite !
68 000 !
69...
Le vélo !
C’est une belle courbe de dons, n’est-ce pas?
Enfin là, c’est genre déjà limite exponentiel.
Là, c’est ridicule en fait.
Ça, ça n’a aucun sens.
Ce truc là, le 16h-22h, il est abusé.
Et c'est bien en train d'arriver.
Allez, allez !
2 millions d'euros !
Allez !
Plus que 2000 balles.
1500 balles !
1000 balles !
500 balles !
Et...
C'est fait !
*Chants*
*Sirène mégaphone*
Oh punaise.
Voilà, on a doublé la cagnotte de l’année dernière quoi.
2 millions d’euros récoltés pour l’Institut Pasteur, c'est ouf.
Ça fait super plaisir.
Juste, on est contentsde faire ce qu’on fait !
Incroyable !
Incroyable.
On est juste contents de fait ce qu'on fait,
contents de voir qu’il y a une communauté aussi généreuse
et qui nous suit dans ce genre de délire donc c’est génial quoi.
On a fait, pour vous donner une idée, à peu près 500 000 euros en 2 heures,
2, 3 heures, ce qui est incroyable.
Je crois qu’il est temps de vous révéler le montant des tee-shirts,
qu’on a gardé un petit peu secret pour tout le monde…
il est de 510 000 euros !
Comme la cagnotte va monter à 2,5 millions,
vous avez pas envie de vous en contenter, je pense?
Non !
Est-ce qu’on va aux 3 millions?
Ouais !
Est-ce qu’on y va avant 1h du matin?
Allez c’est parti !Vous savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire !
Les gens sont tellement généreux.
J'ai eu des 1500 euros, des 1000 euros,
enfin...
C'est juste fou que les gens soient réunis autour d'une cause qui est positive
et ça renvoie une image qui est super pour le gaming
et pour tout ce qu'on fait pour le streaming.
Quand il faut se réunir pour le bien,
on sait le faire.
Moins de 2000 !
Moins de 1000 !
*Cris de joie*
*Chants*
Pasteur !
La coupe à la maison.
Yes !
C’est pas fini encore, c’est ça qui est ouf,
c'est qu'il reste encore 1 heure et demie,
il reste encore un peu de voix.
3 millions quand même, c’est incroyable donc…
3 M !
Je sais pas quoi dire mais c’est ouf, c’est vraiment ouf.
Bravo toi.
Bravo, bravo frérot, t’as tout donné.
Ça fait plaisir !
Bravo, mec !
Ah ouais, là c’est vrai que c'est full émotion quoi.
On va pas se mentir, 3 millions.
J’ai même pas tweeté donc imaginez.
Trop fier.
Hâte demain, que BFM sorte peut-être un article
sur les jeux vidéo qui rendent violent mais bon,
en attendant, on a levé 3 M les gars.
Messieurs dames, on se rapproche peu à peu de la fin du Z Event, malheureusement.
On a levé 3 millions, c’est génial.
Les gens qui ont organisé ça sont juste ici, Zerator et Dach,
on peut les applaudir s’il vous plaît quand même.
*Applaudissements*
Sans eux, il y aurait pas tout ça.
Bravo !
Il reste un objectif ultime,si ça vous amuse.
On est globalement à 250 000 balles d’éclater le record
de tous les marathons caritatifs de Twitch, ever !
*Applaudissements*
Allez, des dons, là, des dons !
Faites des dons !
C'est bientôt le rush final.
Des 1 euro, des 2 euros !
Donnez tout, mesdames et messieurs !
Donnez tout !
Toutes ces causes-là me tiennent tellement à cœur.
Vous imaginez pas à quel pointvous avez changé ma vie
et à quel point on vient de changerla vie de plein de gens...
Et voilà, on va les dépasser.
3,5 millions !
*Cris de joie*
Incroyable !
Z Event 2019 devient l'événement caritatif qui a levé le plus d'argent sur Twitch !
*Cris de joie*
Au monde !
Ça y est !
C'est fait !
*Applaudissements*
Pasteur !
Merci à tous,
c'est aussi grâce à vous.
C'est grâce, aussi, à tous les viewers qui sont là.
Applaudissements pour les viewers, s'il vous plaît, une dernière fois.
*Applaudissements*
Merci beaucoup !
Une fois, j'ai dit un truc dans un live, c'était :
"Vous faites de nos vies un rêve.
On essaie d'embellir les vôtres."
Et je pense que ce soir, c'est hyper vrai.
On a essayé de se donner à fond pendant 3 jours,
tous ensemble pour lever des fonds pour l'Institut Pasteur
et ils sont très reconnaissants pour ça.
On est tous très émus d'avoir pu le faire
grâce à vous.
Donc, merci encore.
Je déclare Z Event terminé pour 2019.
Merci à tous !
*Applaudissements*
Merci beaucoup !
Merci d'avoir participé à tout ça !
C'est la fin de Z Event !
Les viewers !
C'est la fin du live !
Ciao, bye bye !
À bientôt ! Au revoir !
*Cris de joie*